hong kong-based entrepreneur ben chang
is packing up the plan is some designers
developer
we locate later this year his company
our sky has created apps for major
finance and fashion companies around the
world
this is a product we develop it is a
stylus for ipad
like the vast majority of companies in
hong kong chang says the city's quality
of life
widespread use of english and business
friendly regulations
have created the ideal place to build
his business in the past decade our sky
has grown from just three developers to
more than 60 employees
this is one of our clients product it is
tracking my face and
if i move the camera moved with me
but now he says a sweeping national
security law that was passed after a
year of pro-democracy protests
is threatening his business it broadly
criminalizes secession
subversion terrorism and collusion with
foreign governments
with up to life in prison and the new
law is pushing companies like chains to
reconsider their future in the city
singapore taipei and tokyo we do
consider
like different cities in august a poll
by the american chamber of commerce in
hong kong
found that 39 of its members who were
surveyed said they have plans to move
capital
assets or operations out of the city
because of the national security law
several countries in the region are
making moves to sway businesses
in hong kong so what can these places
offer companies like chang's and which
will he choose
what you need to do from a site
selection perspective is you need to
look at first of all what are those
factors both critical and important
that drive the success of a business for
nearly 30 years john evans and his firm
tractus asia
have been advising companies like
kellogg's boeing and metlife
where to set up offices in the region
he says the most important factor
companies have historically looked at
first
is the cost of operating in a city which
includes real estate
salaries and utilities companies have
gravitated to hong kong or singapore
because of corporate taxes which are far
lower than australia and japan
next up the city's connectivity to other
places
this is everything from how easy it is
to get to the airport to how long you
have to sit on a plane
until you meet your client before the
pandemic
airports in seoul and hong kong have the
most number of destinations
with singapore tokyo and taipei not far
behind
companies need to be able to rely on an
independent and efficient legal system
so if they ever go to court they can be
assured that they'll be given a fair
trial
south korea and japan are often held up
as asian democracies with effective
judiciaries
and finally an increasingly important
factor is risk
the fukushima nuclear disaster that's
when
c-suites started to think about risk
more importantly
than with the rising costs of china and
then the u.s china trade war
followed very closely by covid risk has
really become i think that important
factor
evan says hong kong's national security
law chips away at the city's rule of law
and increases the political risk
companies can face
and that's a cost ben chang says his
company can't afford
we start getting some letters from the
legal department of our clients
asking about like where our data store
the recent
national security law make them worry
about if they should continue
using our service for some clients chang
has had to comply with strict european
union data protection and privacy
regulations
but now he says he could be held liable
for violating those
if hong kong police used the national
security law during an investigation
to collect data or order it deleted
online
this law will not undermine human rights
and freedoms
the hong kong government has said the
law won't affect people's basic freedoms
and that only time and facts will tell
that the law will not undermine human
rights
but chang says this promise doesn't
reassure him and realizes he can't store
his client's data in hong kong
and guarantee them that it will be safe
so he's chosen to move part of his staff
out of the city
his decision is based on two factors
being in a democratic country where he
can guarantee the protection of his
client's data
and a city with a good quality of life
so he can attract talent
the immediate thing we are going to do
is to celebrate new offers
in uk uh london especially for storing
data
for our western clients and also we will
have office in both taipei and
in japan these two locations are just
very popular so to retain our talent we
have to open office there
there is one wild card that chang and
other companies could consider
in a bid to lure businesses countries in
the region are planning special
incentives
japan is discussing plans to make it
easier for people in finance to get
visas
taiwan opened a dedicated government
office to help companies move
and one australian lawmaker is pushing
to lower the corporate tax rate
your location decision should never be
driven by
incentives be they tax or non-tax
incentives
incentives are the the icing on the cake
it's the sweetener that
allows you to make a decision so which
cities have john evans clients inquired
about the most recently
if china is the market you're pursuing
you might as well set up in a place like
shanghai
if you're concerned about risks that
come
with doing business in china then
singapore by far
is the easiest and most effective
location
to quickly relocate out of hong kong
for now only a handful of companies have
publicly announced their hong kong
departure
the new york times said it would move
part of its staff to seoul because the
national security law has created
uncertainty about the newspaper's
operations and noted difficulties
obtaining visas for some hong kong-based
staffers
while south korean tech company naver
announced it had moved its data back of
center to singapore according to a
statement provided to local media
ben chang says it's just a matter of
time before other businesses
follow their lead out of hong kong we
used
to have an advantage here in hong kong
we are in the middle
of east and west so a lot of companies
setting up office here
would enjoy both the culture of the
western market
at the same time they can also go into
china but
now people realize that they have to
rethink hong kong
in the future